hey Gary my name is mark source ASIMO
you might remember me from this little
incident please bye Gary's book my life
depends on it by it my question for you
today is this I have
39,000 Instagram followers instagram.com
slash mark and I average about 250 likes
per photo but I also run the Instagram
account for the company that I work for
we have a 6,000 followers and we also
average about 250 likes per photo what
am I doing wrong on my personal account
I must be doing something right because
I have the follower count but they're
not let's get into this Oh mark couple
things I do remember you you're great
dude thanks for being on the show
uh you know there's two things that
stand out it took a few minutes to look
because I wanted to give a good answer
here not just a generally answer number
one Vimeo is a beloved brand to that
community more so than you are to your
community for a couple reasons one I
just think a lot of people followed
Instagram slash mark because it's
Instagram slash mark right you have like
like that's a that we saw that in
Twitter days the people that got there
like real name stuff have exponentially
more followers because we're like who
are these people before and in a world
where Instagram doesn't have verify
there's like who is this guy I literally
think some people are following you so
they think you're mark sanchez or some
like other mark so I do believe that you
have an inflated number of followers who
actually don't give a rat's ass about
you but they're just following you
because of that name that's not to dis
but that's just what I believe uh number
two looking at the accounts very easily
and tierod put up a little sample of
both right here I don't if you can frame
it but like you know and I don't maybe
you can go through like showing six of
the photos here so what do you see
difference what do you see difference
that's what I keep Steve around from
Grammer what's the difference you see in
these things here's the core thing Vimeo
is putting a ton of human beings in
their pictures you are not and I think a
strategy of making it more human not
just landscape and pretty pictures would
really help you don't forget Instagram
is a platform that there's a lot of
human
motion to it it's still a more authentic
place than some of the other social
networks though landscaping and
beautiful pictures work human over
indexes and more importantly you don't
have a mix that problem is you have a
mix and I think you need a mix of the
two and so those would be the core
things